hey Tom Nate and Rebecca here with the
outdoor boys YouTube channel and today
we are eating cookies made from black
walnuts that we harvested out of our
yard so we're gonna show you how to
shell and husk in the harvest black
walnuts and how to make some awesome
recipes out of them
[Music]
all right so this is a black walnut tree
you see how it's got kind of this
wrinkly bark here and if you look up
it's got very distinct leaves you can
see it's got these green things that
look kind of like tennis balls hanging
from it they're all over and the walnuts
when they fall from the ground it look
like this the kind of these green balls
that turn black and squishy and they
fall apart and you can see here there's
the wallet the hard nut we're used to
eating is it in the middle there we got
tons of them they're everywhere
[Music]
black walnuts have this black sap that
you can use to tan leather it's caustic
it'll actually drive earthworms on the
ground so if you want to collect
earthworms you can use tea made from the
SAP and it'll stain your hands
it'll also kill vegetation so if you
have a bunch of black walnuts on the on
your lawn like I do you want to get them
off anyways plus they they go crazy when
the lawnmower hits them so get them off
the lawn is good and if you can eat them
that's just a bonus
well the tree has dropped about half of
its walnuts and it's enough to fill up
this entire bin but it's mostly husks
and leaves and stuff so what we're gonna
do is I'm gonna remove the husks and
leaves and check them off the edge of
the lawn here and dump the actual walnut
seeds into this bucket here so we're
gonna try to separate and most the time
they just squish right out you can see
it's kind of this soft husk just comes
right off so leave us we're gonna check
off now don't wear good clothes and wear
our gloves because this stuff will stain
everything stain it black that smells
kind of like wood varnish well we got a
five-gallon bucket
brimming full of these wet nuts so we
need to sort out the good ones and the
bad ones we need to keep cleaning them
off get rid of all these little maggots
that live in the husks so here we go
[Music]
[Applause]
I'm out let these sectors dry for a
little while here we are guys two months
later it's almost Christmas time and and
these walnuts have been drying in the
garage and they look like they're ready
to eat they're nice and clean not
getting rid of my hands that dirty so
you can see it's leaving a little bit of
black powder a little bit of dust is
coming off a but not much so let's break
them open and get them shell
yeah these walnuts are really tough the
shells on them are much thicker than
domestic walnuts check this out
[Music]
do smell sweet okay from one walnut
here's all the shells and here's all the
meat so as you can see it's a lot less
meat a lot more shell than than a
domestic walnut which is pretty typical
I mean all domestic fruits seemed to be
a little bit bigger you know then the
wild stuff
but the smell is fantastic so I can't
wait to try this is I mean it just
smells sweet is the best way to describe
it so we're gonna give this a taste try
some here try some Tommy
the flavor is different I don't like it
it's like a walnut flavor but there's
something else there's yeah there's a
definite a stronger flavor it's almost a
cab pizza well there's a real trick to
this just kind of tap tap tap oh there
you go you feel it when it starts to
crack and then you want to stop you
don't want to blow it into smithereens
just want to get it open and then we can
pick it clean inside where it's warm it
is 30 degrees right now
the stepper and it is called I am super
impressed it's open like seriously these
are these are hard shells well I gotta
tell you having an anvil really helped
it betters the back then I don't have to
be bending over is really great but you
can do this on concrete or on the rock
or any hard surface
[Music]
look at his huge pile of walnuts man
these things are awesome it took me a
while to crack em open I probably spent
40 minutes 30 minutes shelling wallets
but now I've got to pick the meat out
and separate the meat from the shells
and it smells awesome all right guys so
let's get pickin and to pick the meat
out I've got a little shish kabob skewer
here just a little long skinny pointy
object to kind of go and pick stuff out
of the shell that's all you really need
all right and I've got of course a bowl
here catch the meat and we'll go from
there
see what happens you helping daddy your
stick is done there's a lot easier with
my little helper here hey tell me having
fun I appreciate your help buddy you're
good at getting the meat out of these
walnuts
so using these shish kabob sticks to pry
out the meats really helpful I mean a
lot of its kind of crumbled up a little
bit we still got some big chunks in here
it's working working pretty good slow
tedious work though no no Tommy if
grandpa was here do you know what he
would say right he would say get off the
table Mabel these two bits of her beer
so we make a wallet root cookies yeah
yeah that sounds good well we've got
enough we can make a lot of cookies Olie
Merrick Oh guys look at this look at
this whole goal wallets here I'm not
even halfway through that's a lot of
nuts
[Music]
want to come here and help me pick out
these little pieces but oh so here we
are picking out the last little bits of
meat and shells from the bottom of the
basket we're almost done well guys it
was a lot of work but we did it took
about six to eight hours to shell this
big basket full of walnuts
and look at it we've got about three
pounds of shell wall and meat and it was
very tedious but it was also kind of
relaxing and I got a bid to watch
x-files so that was kind of fun but do
you like it
mmm that smells good you like that does
that smell good yeah so now we've got to
do some fun things with all of these
wallets that we've collected from our
front yard so I'm gonna make some walnut
oatmeal cookies and il be a reward for
my little boys for helping me out yeah
yeah that's how good you want some
cookies yeah let's do it all right now
three pounds Oh Wallace is a lot of
walnuts there's a lot of different
things you could make with this you can
make black walnut pie banana nut bread
but I'm gonna make some oatmeal walnut
and raisin cookies here for the for the
boys but I'm gonna have a lot of
leftovers and I'll probably just use
those to sprinkle them on pancakes and
oatmeal and put in muffins and things
like that any rate I'm gonna make some
cookies
yeah it doesn't have to be hard I've got
myself some of these ready-made cookie
mixes I got some oatmeal cookies here
I'm going to add the mix some butter
some eggs some a little bit of water and
then a load of walnuts and some of these
crazes the cranberry raisins and now
we're gonna make some cookies
[Music]
all right so once you got your batter
mixing pretty well go ahead and add a
bunch of crazy alright once you got the
raisins mixed in add your walnuts
well I did a double batch of oatmeal
walnut raisin cookies and I still have a
ton of walnuts leftover which is just
fine by me I'm gonna sprinkle leaves on
all sorts of fun things over the next
few months and I'm gonna put them in the
refrigerator because they have a just a
fabulous smell and flavor to them and I
want to keep that as that fresh flavor
as long as I can so technically you
could just put it in any sealed
container keep it at room temperature
and it will last a very long time that
way as well so but anyway we'll put my
stash in the refrigerator
well check this out I've got a massive
pile of walnut shell and you know what I
think I'm gonna do I think I'm gonna
save these and I might experiment with
using them in my fish smoker it just
smells fabulous I love the smell of them
and the size is just right for smoking
all right well these are pretty good
looking little cookies I'll let them
cool and we're gonna tuck in these taste
do you like these cookies Tommy I really
like them too normally when you have
like walnuts and cookies they're just
kind of a texture but they don't have a
bunch of a flavor these have a lot of
flavor it is it makes the whole cookie
taste like wild black walnuts and it's
really good yeah it's it's different
than any food you can buy in the store
it's it's awesome well we got a ton of
this we still have like three pounds of
walnuts
we barely put barely put a dent in the
walnut well I hope you enjoyed this
video about harvesting black walnuts if
you want to see more videos like this
from the outdoor boys youtube channel
don't forget to that's right click
subscribe and don't forget to click that
Bell button to get notifications because
we put out new videos every week thanks
for watching